[Music]
I'm pretty sure that as a kid you must
have played with magnets kids are always
curious to find out about the things
that get attracted to a magnet let me
list out a few of the things that get
attracted to a magnet and I Neal screwed
the door of a fridge the belt buckles
and so on these are just a handful of
objects that a magnet gets attracted to
what about the objects that do not get
attracted by a magnet well there are so
many that we can find in your house
clothes wooden doors wooden tables or to
name a few
or to be more specific we will say that
wood fabric and plastic do not get
attracted to a magnet but what exactly
are these objects yes they are nonmetals
you wouldn't find any non metallic
object around you that will get
attracted to the magnet so can I say
that all nonmetals do not get attracted
to a magnet not really there are a few
nonmetals like oxygen that get attracted
to the magnet
especially when oxygen is in liquid form
however they get attracted to only
powerful magnets and not the ordinary
ones that we come across so at this
level it is okay if we say that
nonmetals are non-magnetic non-magnetic
means that they do not attract magnets
hence if you bring a magnet in front of
a nonmetallic part of a body then it
will not stick to it and now if
nonmetals do not get attracted by a
magnet then does that mean that metals
always do some metals get attracted to
the magnet while some don't what are the
metals that get attracted to the magnet
the most common metal is iron of course
apart from iron nickel cobalt and steel
also attract iron but if you bring a
magnet in front of a copper or aluminium
they will not be attracted to it again
there are exceptions some of the metals
like copper do attract too powerful
magnet
but four small magnets no attraction is
observed so we can say that the only
metals that get attracted to a magnet
are iron nickel cobalt and steel the
materials that are attracted by a magnet
are called magnetic materials and the
materials that are strongly attracted to
a magnet are called ferromagnetic
materials I nickel and cobalt are
ferromagnetic
if they bring a magnet in front of a
cooker or a steel plate that we serve
food on then you will not find the
attraction but hold on I just said that
the steel is attracted to a magnet so
what is wrong with these things these
are made of stainless steel and it is
one specific type of steel not all the
stainless steel materials attract
magnets but many do
hence we consider steel as magnetic
[Music]
you